Hi, I'm Eric Voss
and The Matrix, the Wachowski cyberpunk masterpiece,
has for the past 20 yrs inspired a revolution
in the philosophy and the aesthetic of Hollywood films
and we mainly go to Blue Ray of every annoying
college roommate ever.
And AS one of those annoying college roommates-
myself I decided to take a break from the usual deep
dives into superheroes, dragons and droids
as philosophical many of them are,
to examine The Matrix scene by scene.
To explore it's influences, how IT influenced nearly
everything that came after it and all the hidden
visual secrets in this movie that you might have missed
the first your friend's older brother who wore
sunglasses a lot showed it to you.
The film opens from the point of view of
the matrix itself.
In the form of this raining green code. The color green
was chosen to reflect the green
tint of early monochrome computer monitors and
and throughout this movie the color green filters
every scene that takes place inside the matrix. In order
to show it's artificiality compared to the REAL world
which is tinted in the color blue. This imagery was
inspired by the opening credits of the famous 1995
anime Ghost In The Shell.
A HUGELY influential manga and film series,
Ghost In The Shell is set in the future where humans
are cybernetically enhanced and their brains can be hacked.
It explores the philosophy of artificial intelligence
and detached identity.